c'est une semaine importante pour les
municipalités qui présentent leur budget
la ville de Québec a présenté son budget
2023 aujourd'hui hausse de 7% du budget
de fonctionnement à un milliard
772 millions de dollars priorité au
projet de tramway toujours au contrôle
des dépenses également création d'une
réserve d'infrastructures pour les
changements climatiques on annonce
également des investissements
supplémentaires dans les services la
gestion des matières résiduelles
l'entretien des rues notamment les coûts
de parcomètre seront augmentés les coûts
des permis de stationnement également
les droits de mutation le maire Bruno
marchand confirme aussi que la hausse
des taxes est limitées à
2,5%, il est avec nous avec grand
plaisir on reçoit le maire de Québec à
Québec bonsoir Monsieur marchand bonsoir
monsieur
je disais où se découpe par commettre du
coût des vignettes de stationnement
aussi les droits de mutation
l'inflation qui frappe un peu tout le
monde est-ce que vous ferez pas un peu
le portefeuille des Québécois des
citoyens de une bonne question et c'est
pour ça qu'on a limité la hausse à deux
points 5% parce qu'on sait que nos
citoyens sont un peu mal pris avec ce
qu'ils voient l'épicerie ce qui va dans
leur loisirs ce qui va dans leurs
activités pour se déplacer et on tenait
absolument malgré que présentement à
Québec on évalue l'inflation à 6 % sur
l'année 2022 à ne pas dépasser 2.5 % et
pour faire ça mais ça obligé de
sacrifices notamment dans les piger dans
réserve notamment de faire découper
faire une gestion serrée de certaines
dépenses et aussi d'augmenter certains
revenus mais c'est des revenus qui
avaient pas augmenté depuis 2016 quand
vous parlez du stationnement on passe la
vignette de stationnement sur rue de 80
à 120 dollars c'est quand même important
mais oublions pas que ça coûte à la
ville pour chaque espace de
stationnement 588 dollars alors le
citoyen reste quand même encore avantagé
largement souvent enseigné soutenu par
la Ville mais oui un effort à faire de
plus et je pense que l'écart est encore
très grand et le citoyen s'en trouve
très bien servi mais ça nous amène des
revenus supplémentaires qui nous
permettent de colmater cet écart entre
nos taxes et l'inflation mais même à 2
et demi pour cent monsieur marchand
c'est vrai que c'est loin de l'inflation
c'est pas mal en bas de l'inflation mais
ça reste l'une des hausses les plus
élevées en plusieurs décennies à Québec
vous avez raison parce que l'inflation a
été dans les dernières décennies autour
de 1.5 rarement deux l'an passé notre
hôtel c'était à 2.1 à côté sur
l'inflation en même temps ce qui compte
c'est aussi les cas c'est les efforts
qu'on fait pour pas refiler ça aux
citoyens c'est ça qui est important
alors l'inflation a jamais été aussi
élevée dans les 10 15 20 dernières
années on se retrouve à des taux
comparables aux années 80 je vous
apprends rien alors on a fait des
efforts colossaux pour ne pas refiler la
totalité de cette facture là et on a les
content de ça et là vous annoncez aussi
des compressions de 11 millions de
dollars est-ce que ça va toucher les
citoyens mais ça touche les citoyens pas
dans les services mais ça touche les
citoyens dans une de gestion des
avantages qui est différente on va
limiter le nombre de places éphémères
qu'on faisait on va limiter les espaces
publics qu'on rendait accessible hiver
de façon à faire en sorte on va
alimenter les vases on va limiter
certaines heures des centres déco les
gens peuvent venir déposer de un gros
déchets de gros rebut des heures qui
étaient pas accessibles ou qui étaient
accessibles mais dont les citoyens se
prévalaient peu donc on essaie de
diminuer l'impact sur les citoyens mais
d'avoir une gestion des dépenses
rigoureuses et c'est ce qu'on fait le
contrôle des dépenses la gestion
rigoureuse dont vous parlez vous avez
beaucoup parlé de réduire la dette
également par rapport à l'ensemble de
l'économie ce qui est un objectif
également de plusieurs gouvernements
mais est-ce que ça vous amène proche de
ce qu'on pourrait appeler de la rigueur
ou de l'austérité dans votre gestion des
finances publiques dans une bonne
question mais non pas du tout puis
d'ailleurs le budget est en haut cette
année mais pour nous c'est important de
contrôler la dette pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord nous sommes une des deux
villes avec Montréal qui est en cotation
avec Moïse qui est en cotation avec des
firmes externes donc ils évaluent entre
autres notre ratio d'être revenu qui est
des qui est au-delà de 95% maintenant
notre objectif c'est de le ramener à 70%
sur 10 ans pourquoi on veut faire ça il
y a une raison de cotation on a une très
bonne cote double A2 cependant on veut
aussi donner de la marge pour les
générations futures c'est aussi pour ça
pourquoi on crée une réserve qui va
atteindre en 2028 300 millions parce
qu'on sait que les changements
climatiques vont nous impacter on sait
qu'on va devoir s'adapter c'est déjà le
cas et si on n'a pas les coûts de France
il y en a une dette qui nous accorde qui
nous donne pas la marge si on n'a pas
une bonne cotation avec nos taux
d'emprunt sont élevés parce que notre
cotation est insuffisante ou il adéquate
mais nécessairement on se pénalise à
réagir face aux différents défis qui
nous attendent on parle de
ralentissement économique mais on parle
aussi de changement climatique on se
donne la marge pour pouvoir agir dans
les prochaines années et pas empiéter
sur les générations futures et ça pour
moi c'est déterminant est-ce que vous
seriez prêt à remettre en question le
projet de tramway à Québec si ça si les
dépassements de coupe par exemple était
trop élevé ça reste quand même un gros
morceau dans votre projet
d'immobilisation oui vous avez raison et
c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours dit
c'est pas le tramway n'importe quel prix
on y croit on va faire en sorte de le
réaliser maintenant on va attendre
d'ouvrir les enveloppes on va attendre
d'avoir le vrai prix mais cela ne
voudrait dire quand on écrit 3 milliards
et demi là c'est pas ça le vrai prix
mais présentement les chiffres on était
à 3 milliards 900 millions et ce que
j'ai dit il y a quelques semaines c'est
qu'il y aurait c'est vraiment une hausse
en raison de l'inflation les hôpitaux à
Montréal à Québec les grands projets les
maisons des années vivent cette
inflation là et on le voit sur les coûts
4 milliards 5 milliards mais on verra je
peux faire la spéculation aujourd'hui ça
serait de sortir des chiffres en l'air
mais on attend le dépôt par les
consortiums notamment du volet
infrastructure qui est le plus grand
volet de notre projet et on va être
capable après discuter avec les paliers
de gouvernement à la fois du Canada et
du Québec pour voir comment on fait pour
assurer la pérennité de ce projet-là
vous vous dites que le projet de tramway
pourrait être mis en question pour des
enjeux budgétaires et de gestion de
dette bah oui mais il peut pas il peut
pas coûter 10 12 15 milliards on peut
pas dire malgré que c'est un projet
auquel on croit malgré que c'est un
projet important pour se déplacer de
façon sobre en carbone c'est un projet
économique c'est un projet social il
peut pas nous coûter 15 milliards vous
avez ce programme en gestionnaire
rigoureux on est obligé de se dire on va
entendre ce que on a prévu on a un bon
bureau de projet on va attendre ce que
les consensions vont nous déposer comme
offre on va l'analyser avec moi 4
milliards et 15 milliards vous vous
donnez quand même pas mal de jeux je
vous ai dit j'avais raison au café mais
je vous ai dit également mais je veux
pas aujourd'hui vous dire voici le
plafond parce que ça serait complètement
je pense mal avisé de vous donner un
plafond parce que quel va être le
contexte je vous donne un exemple si on
trouve son temps en ralentissement
économique ce projet-là va avoir une
grande valeur parce que ralentissement
économique de pouvoir investir 4
milliards dans l'économie locale du
Québec parce qu'ils vont des contrats à
Montréal des contrats à Québec 4
milliards c'est pas banal dans une
économie qui est en ralentissement là ça
pourrait peut-être nous sauver faire du
ralentissement économique donc on va
attendre de voir qu'est-ce que les
consortium nous déposent est-ce qu'on a
le bon prix pour la valeur du projet
puis après ça on pourra communiquer les
citoyens voici combien il coûte et voici
pourquoi on va de l'avant ou voici
pourquoi on pense que c'est réaliste
vous aviez promis de baisser les taxes
des commerçants allez vous faire ben pas
cette année on est à 2.5%, on le fait
danser on a été la seule municipalité se
prévaloir du nouveau projet de loi qui
permettait un crédit taxe au commerçants
on a on était la seule des grandes
municipalités en prévaloir on a affaire
un cri du taxe à passer qui a été
bienvenue dans un temps de pandémie de
cette année on est à 2.5% notre objectif
c'est de rétablir l'équilibre entre les
commerçants de Québec et les commerçants
du Québec et les commerçants du Canada
parce qu'on avait vu dans des rapports
notamment de KPMG où on était surtaxé
alors par une limitation du rose de
taxes la hausse des taxes on va
nécessairement couvrir une partie de
cette espace là pour l'instant on va
voir dans les prochaines années qu'on
peut faire mais on aspire toujours avoir
un environnement encore plus
concurrentiel le dernier mot l'ancien
maire de Gatineau Maxime penaud Jobin
directement dans la presse que les
villes s'investissent beaucoup dans de
nouveaux domaines tout simplement parce
que c'est absolument nécessaire et qui
devient chaque jour de plus en plus
nécessaire que le Québec adapte sa
fiscalité municipale à toute cette
nécessité à la nécessité de la réalité
du terrain vous êtes où dans votre
réflexion là dessus à la même place
madame plante partage les mêmes propos
et leur raison on va vous donner des
exemples de Québec dans le budget actuel
cette année en 2023 l'année prochaine
c'est 18 millions le fonctionnement de
notre usine de biométhanisation c'est
c'est la mise en oeuvre c'est la
distribution des sacs c'est tout ce
qu'on va faire pour faire de l'énergie
circulaire à partir des déchets de table
mais c'est un engagement du gouvernement
du Québec c'est une responsabilité qu'on
nous confie mais pour lequel on n'a pas
le soutien nécessaire c'est la même
chose à plusieurs égards l'itinérance
qui augmente on a besoin de notre
partenaire les discussions vont bon
train on paraît on parlait au début de
changement climatique s'adapter au
changement climatique là c'est pas
s'adapter au poste adapté c'est est-ce
qu'on le fait maintenant et ça coûte
moins cher ou on le fait plus tard
devant la panique devant les crises et
ça coûte plus cher l'option de ne pas
s'adapter n'existe pas il va falloir
s'adapter à adapter nos villes nos
infrastructures et en ce sens mais c'est
pour ça qu'on travaille avec le
gouvernement du Québec et du Canada il
faut agir maintenant monsieur Bachard
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI